[Music]
gina joins us in nashville tennessee
gina welcome to the ramsay show
hi uh
uh george and rachel how are you today
doing great how are you
oh good thanks uh so i'm employed right
now and i want to take out about twenty
thousand dollars out of my 401k
uh to pay off about two thousand dollars
in federal back taxes and have an
emergency fund
because
i haven't been keeping the job very well
ever since we moved
out to this area from california last
year
and i'm also working on paying down my
student debt so i wanted to know if you
think that this is a bad idea for me to
hit it this way
yeah if i had a giant buzzer on this
desk that could go ah i would hit it
right now but i don't so i'll just make
the mouth noise gina this it's a bad
move and i'm glad you called before you
make this move we never ever advise
anyone to pull money from the 401k
because you're unplugging all of the
hard work that you've put into it that
compound interest is doing for you and
there's another way to do this you can
clean up this mess and get this
emergency fund in place with your income
that you have so what is your household
income
uh well right now it's pretty much my
husband's and it's about 30 000 a year
uh we we literally have no money
and uh and this this these back taxes
federal back taxes over my head i need
to get them clear cleaned up so would
you consider taking out a lesser amount
like 5000 or so i mean i'm willing to
take the hit i'm 60.
um so you know i don't mind just
incurring it in the taxes as income just
to get this off my back and how much is
the ir how much is that again did you
say
it's around two thousand that's what
penalties and then trying tina you can
do this you uh go drive uber eats work
work i mean do anything you can to make
money do not take money out of that 401k
it's 2 000 you can do it but it does
need to be the very first thing whenever
you have irs debt that's the very first
thing you pay off but gina you guys can
do this you need to get this income up
and and it is possible people are hiring
everywhere right now there's a shortage
of labor so go
follow your pride get any job you can
and get yourself in a good financial
situation